[Musique]
2019 elle s'est ouvert c'est le nouveau
corps d'un virus qui est en train de se
développer façon fulgurante et qui
inquiète tout le monde et pas uniquement
la paix mais aujourd'hui on parle de
l'aide
[Musique]
bon jeu mais en version lutter contre
coronavirus prête le corner les russes
vous le savez vous l'avez pas louper un
tout le monde en parle dans l'actualité
de tous les côtés c'est normal parce que
c'est une épidémie qui se développe
assez rapidement qui impacte beaucoup de
monde c'est quand même très très très
très très inquiet dans tout ça
non pas que ce soit 9 forcément la fin
du monde annoncée ne vous inquiétez pas
des épidémies y en a déjà eu le sras en
2003 et avait pas mal
c'est une nouvelle étude il faut faire
attention donc aujourd'hui je vais vous
parler du corona virus à l'asthme mais
bien à l'aise et je me mets en condition
le seul problème c'est que nos caméras
risque de ne pas marquer ce que vous
pensez à détection de visages ça marche
hop je mets le masque jeux les plus
détection du visage bon fallait autant
de journées du coronavirus parce que
tout simplement c'est un pacte beaucoup
de secteurs beaucoup de domaines
beaucoup de monde allait mieux comme ça
mais ça impacte également le secteur de
la tech alors c'est un petit peu
compliqué tout ça parce que vous serez
pas sans savoir que en asie et plus
précisément en chine pas qu'en chine
mais également à taïwan ya aussi la
corée eh bien vous avez le coeur du
poumon technologiques les principaux
fournisseurs sont là bas le savoir faire
est là bas donc lorsque vous avez un
gros problème endémique là bas une
épidémie là bas il ya tout ça un petit
peu compliqué ça impacte le reste du
monde aujourd'hui je peux vous parler de
l'épidémie tel quel et je ne vais pas
vous parler de santé publique je vais
aujourd'hui la c4 est pas ma taille en
fait c'est la taille de ma femme qu'elle
est plus petites mains que moi ma femme
et affirmé hier voilà pourquoi j'ai le
matériel
alors je vois pas du virus tel qu'il est
je vais pas vous parler de l'épidémie je
peux vous parler de la mortalité soit
vous paraître tout ça parce que je suis
pas expert là dedans et qu'il ya des
médias qu'ils font très très très très
bien ma par contre je vous parler
aujourd'hui de l'aspect tech du côté
tech comment est-ce que ça risque de
mettre en danger l'économie des attaques
contre gaza risque de la ralentir pour
le moment pas que la tech smartphones
mais avec un peu globale sans toucher un
peu tout le monde sera touché
l'automobile ça va toucher lé télévision
ça va toucher bien évidemment l'audio ça
touchait beaucoup beaucoup de monde est
effectivement le broker ça reste le
smartphone il y en plus en ce moment un
risque d'augmentation du nouvel an
chinois qui lui il ya pas très longtemps
donc il se peut vraiment qu'il y ait un
risque de la propagation de l'épidémie
pour l'instant ce n'est pas trop où on
en est sa maîtresse à un certain temps
j'imagine va finir par se réguler j'ose
espérer mais au travers des conséquences
veut pas dire délétère mais très
compliqué en tout cas du point de vue de
la taille du pot de vue l'économie par
rapport à ce qu'il est aujourd'hui et
par rapport à ce qui pourrait arriver le
premier point c'est un ralentissement au
niveau de l'activité en chine
vous n'êtes pas sans savoir que quand
même pas mal de
prison dix ans effectivement bon et bien
rester chez vous beaucoup de talent et
travail
restez chez vous bossez chez vous ne
sortez pas on va éviter de se rencontrer
pour éviter de se contaminer le
coronavirus comme beaucoup de virus vont
se propager dans l'air par contact le
postillon les mains sales posez vous
posez vos doigts tac tac tac vous
contaminer comme une bonne gastro comme
une bonne grippe à se propage assez
rapidement donc du coup et d'entreprises
ont dit ok restez chez vous on se met de
côté tout va bien en grade un peu ce
qu'il en ait enfin un point
et puis dans 14 jours si vous avez rien
eu c'est que vous n'êtes pas malade et
puis à ce moment là on verra comment la
situation évolue donc ça c'est bien sauf
que ça mais quand même pas mal
d'activité en berne il ya plusieurs
boutiques apple en chine qui ont réduit
leurs horaires d'ouverture qui dit
réduction d'horaires d'ouverture dit
moins de flux dans le magasin dit du
coup moins de risques de contamination
puisque vous avez moins de personnes qui
passent par là un plus gros focus qui a
été fait au niveau religieux ou
j'imagine que tout le monde est comme ça
puisque la propagation c'est quand même
par les voies respiratoires
vous protégez vous bloquez comme ça vous
êtes tranquille voilà donc déjà ça c'est
vachement sa face à un copain de type
home / jeune a tenté de faire une vidéo
comme ça voyez avec elles les banques
est le masque son visage faut pas qu'ils
tombent faut être bien protégé se
protéger soit protégé je voyais un peu
l'histoire donc du coup moins de flux
dans les magasins - risque de
contamination donc des boutiques qui
ouvre moi un chiffre d'affaires en
baisse par rapport aux boutiques
fatalement les mêmes google qui a
encouragé ses employés à travailler de
chez eux pour justement ne pas se
croiser une passe contaminés et diminuer
la propagation de l'épidémie
et il ya notamment une usine qui est
très connu un fort essor très connu qui
s'appelle foxconn foxconn qui
d'entreprise taïwanaise qui fournit de
très très grands et notamment apple qui
est un des fournisseurs majeurs d'apple
pour l'instant foxconn a fermé ses
usines et lyon voudra pas avant mi
février ce qui veut dire que la
production pour l'instant elle est
arrêtée il ya plus rien qu'il s'en aille
a parlé qui se produiront je sais pas
d'ailleurs si vous avez suivi ma vidéo
de rumeurs d'il ya quelques jours sur
les rumeurs de l'iphone et ceux de
iphone qui pourrait sortir très
prochainement une fois de plus les
rumeurs fantasque froide en écran de 4,7
pouces soit dans l'écran de 5,4 pouce
pour l'instant on est encore un peu sur
des rumeurs rien n'est confirmé mais ça
pourrait arriver et ce qui pourrait en
tout cas poser un problème pour l'iphone
et ce2 mais aussi pour les iphone par
contre ils seront annoncées au mois de
septembre prochain tout simplement avec
la fabrication de composants puisque un
ralentissement de l'activité
le carnet de commandes est là il ya un
ralentissement ça ne produit pas tu donc
tout va se décaler et est ce que tous
les produits sont livrés à leur ce qui
est toujours un peu compliqué est ce que
foxconn a de l'avancé au niveau des
pièces oui
toujours est il qu'à un moment ou un
autre ça va impacter l'industrie de la
tête là je vous parle de foxconn
mais y'a pas que foxconn il y en a
énormément yann marti dans les échos qui
est intéressante de sébastien dumoulin
qui vous parle effectivement de l'ateq
mondial où lille titre la tête mondial
redoute d'être contaminé par le coran
navires russes chinois ça explique à qui
veut toutes les inquiétudes
on vous parle des différentes
entreprises dans la province de one et
notamment regarder ça donc deux
entreprises qui appartiennent à un géant
chinois de l'électronique qui
représenterait 5 % de la production
mondiale de mémoire flash celles
utilisées dans les clés usb les
smartphones ou les appareils photos ça
veut dire qu'on touche vraiment des
secteurs entiers de l'économie
alors ça c'est un point important il ya
eu une autre point en part effectivement
de recul boursier le jeu et aller vers
cet article je vous demande rien dans la
description est vraiment intéressant et
toute une partie marquée semaine
cruciale pour apple
parce que ça montre effectivement de
quelle manière apple et notamment apple
n'est pas que apple peut être impacté le
géant californien sous traite la
production de ses appareils en grande
partie à foxconn et pegatron sur des
sites distants de plusieurs centaines de
kilomètres de wuhan
mais ce n'est pas une garantie
immunitaire pour des milliers d'ouvriers
qui assemble ses smartphones et ses
tablettes
l'épidémie a créé un potentiel problèmes
logistiques complexes pour la production
d'iphone qui va monter en puissance en
février prochain ses objectifs explique
dan eyes analyste chez wedbush
securities
les prochaines semaines seront cruciales
car si le virus n'est pas contenu cela
pourrait déstabiliser la production
d'iphone en chine ce qui serait un sujet
majeur d'inquiétude pour les
investisseurs
la firme à la pomme publie mardi soir
ses résultats new dream alors ça je vous
dis donc voilà en fait le problème est
vraiment global c'est extrêmement
inquiétant article super intéressant des
'echos' amoncellement de quelle manière
les différents secteurs de la tec sont
impactés par provient du corps en
alliage donc là je vous parle tout de
suite des risques au niveau des
fournisseurs au niveau des pièces au
niveau des produits finis qui pourrait
arriver plus tard et l'ajout parle
d'apple il y en a aussi beaucoup
beaucoup d'autres mais il ya aussi un
autre problème faut pas oublier
qu'aujourd'hui la chine comme je vous
laisse un acteur international d'acteur
mondial au niveau des technologies
il ya quelques jours c'est pas si vous
vous souvenez il ya des services à las
vegas je vous emmener au soleil vous
êtes tout montrer les nouveautés signées
ça mais il ya dans quelques jours allez
en trois semaines trois semaines et
demie trois semaines pendant trois
semaines un salon majeur au niveau du
smartphone qui s'appelle le mobile world
congress le mwc qui a lieu tous les ans
à barcelone qui est la grande messe du
smartphone tout a lieu là bas tout le
monde se rende compte fournisseurs
fabricants la presse tout le monde est
là tout ce beau monde se rend compte
quatre jours de salon trois jours à font
plus tout ce qui se passe à côté et vous
serez pas sans savoir que qui dit
tec 10 chine dit asie tout le monde de
latex d'asie lié aux smartphones qui se
déplace au mwc
ça veut dire un grand déplacement de
population je sais pas si vous avez
suivi l'actualité complète dans les
médias il ya beaucoup de compagnies
aériennes qui ont arrêté leur vol par la
chine continentale pour nos droits on
dit la chine mais l'épidémie elle se
propage un petit peu il ya effectivement
taiwan et la corée du nord il fera que
casser où il ya les cas au japon on sait
aujourd'hui où on en est à un instant t
on sait par où est ce qu'on sera au
niveau du virus dans quelques jours il
ya un site sur lequel vous pouvez avoir
toutes les informations concernant le
nombre de cas l'évolution du cours d'un
virus et compagnie eh bien voyez qu'en
ce moment il ya douze mille 24 cas
directement présent il ya 2 159 décès et
on voit vraiment que la grosse zone qui
impactait ça reste quand même la chine
en chine continentale vous avez 11 1864
pour 12000 24k globale ce qui est énorme
la thaïlande 19 le japon 17 c thaïlande
quand même
la corée du sud 12 c'est pas énorme mais
malgré tout il faut voir comment les
choses se développent donc imaginer 1
mwc 100 chinois sans japonais en coréen
je vois pas comment ça peut marcher je
vous fais un petit récap il va y avoir à
ce moment là une conférence devant
ouvrir le dimanche
huawei chinois une conférence de schumi
le dimanche il y aura le 1010 de
présenter shiomi chinois une conférence
dopo le samedi au pot chinois une
conférence de tcl le samedi tcl chinois
une conférence de sony le lundi sonnez
japonais il y aura une conférence de
honor le lundi au nord chinois et y aura
bien évidemment tous les stands
notamment le grand stand de samsung
samsung coréen et le hall 2 qui est
quasiment pris par huawei pour parler de
smart sicli pour parler de 5 g autant
vous dire que s'il n'y a pas de présence
chinoise nippone coréenne au mwc
ça me paraît très compliqué ça soulève
même la question dû se dire est ce que
le mwc aura lieu est ce que mwc 2020
existera si l'asie ne peut pas être
présente et là je vous parle du mwc
mais il ya aussi tous les lancements qui
vont arriver d'ici quelques jours va y
avoir le lancement de samsung auquel je
serai présent le 11 février à san
francisco san soo mieux est une
entreprise sud coréenne
il ya des cas à séoul pas autant qu'en
chine il ya quand même quelques cas bien
que la conférence aura lieu aux états
unis il va y avoir la conférence de
moins jouer fin mars à paris est-ce
qu'elle va être impactée à cause du
virus c'est par un probable on sait pas
réellement bon sera l'épidémie à ce
moment là on sait pas réellement qu'est
ce qui va se passer contre ce qui est
sûr c'est ce que l'impact est pas mal
mais aussi où en plus ce qui arrivera
probablement au mois de mai 2
26 c'est pas un petit peu avant donc
qu'est-ce qui se passe comment est ce
qu'ils peuvent faire chez caa côté un
peu malin il ya déjà des entreprises qui
se sont dit ok on va prendre nos
employés ceux qui doivent bouger on va
les mettre en quarantaine pendant 14
jours
séparément une quarantaine ce n'est pas
40 jours mais c'est 14 jours c'est la
période d'incubation du virus
eh bien il ya des entreprises qui ont
dit ok on va prendre des employés on va
les mettre de côté pendant 14 jours ici
sous 14 jours ils n'ont pas développé le
virus et bien on peut les envoyer
ça prouve qu'ils n'ont aucun problème
aucun risque et à ce moment là on les
envoie directement c'est un côté un peu
malsain petit hack qui est en train
d'être mis en place ne peux pas le faire
pour tous vous imaginez vos pas mettre
des dizaines de milliers tard seul
devant des centaines de milliers de
personnes de côté pendant 14 jours et
ensuite on sait que ce n'est pas malade
ils peuvent voyager ça me paraît un peu
compliquée alors là je vous parle de
l'asie qui voyagent pour revenir à des
salons extérieurs à des événements
extérieurs mais aussi tous les voyages
de l'extérieur vers l'asie notamment
vers la chine qui pour l'instant sont un
peu bloqués sont un peu en croit jusqu'à
certaines entreprises qui ont dit ok
pour l'instant on bloque tout on ne va
pas en chine
on ne voyage pas là bas on ne prend pas
le risque donc toutes ces collaborations
qu'il va être faite sur place pour
l'instant c'est bloqué tous les voyages
de presse pour aller voir des nouveautés
produits pour l'instant ces blocs et
donc à tout un pan de l'économie qui est
bloqué je vous parle beaucoup de
smartphones mais aussi psa les usines en
chine il eu des fermetures d'usinés du
rapatriement de personnel yarn aucune
usine à roanne qui est l'épicentre de
l'épidémie
elle ne vous parle pas encore de nissan
fiat chrysler ford et general motors
enfin il ya quand même pas mal
d'entreprises qui sont intacts et tout
ça bien évidemment créer une inquiétude
en bourse ce qui peut déstabiliser les
entreprises pose un réel problème à
moyen terme
il faut savoir qu'il ya un tiers de la
production chinoise d'écrans oled qui
proviennent de la province de hebei
autour de wuhan
alors qui dit écran oled dit bien
évidemment téléviseur dits smartphones
des écrans oled sont quasiment partout
donc ça peut aussi être problématique de
ce côté là ce qui ressort de tout ça
c'est que si on arrive à endiguer
l'épidémie soit elle diminue très
rapidement la contagion s'arrête les cas
diminue la mortalité arrive à être
endiguée et pourquoi pas un vaccin pour
être mis en place ça serait globalement
idéal si on peut parler d'idéal là
dessus soit l'épidémie
sur la contagion augmente qui est plus
en plus de cas en chine et dans le reste
du monde ça va bloquer les voyages
internationaux
ça va bloquer tous les événements ça va
bloquer l'industrie globale autour de
l'attaqué même pas que de la tech le
monde entier parce que tout est impacté
le monde rend dans une crise enfin je
vous raconte pas c'est sûr c'est le
bordel ça manque en tout cas quel point
les dépendances aujourd'hui d'un point
de vue technologique de la chine et de
façon vraiment flagrante extrêmement un
peu flippante
aujourd'hui c'est un virus qui pose
problème ça veut donc dire que c'est le
fait du virus qui bloque et pour des
questions de santé publique
on prend des précautions ont dit ok vous
restez là côté on attend comment ça se
passe on essaie d'endiguer la maladie
why not sa salle principale mais
imaginez on prend le problème à l'envers
c'est pas une épidémie imaginer que ce
soit par exemple dans le gouvernement
chinois qui décident de travailler
autrement eh bien ça sera une fois de
plus tout le monde de la terre
international qui serait intacte et
pourquoi simplement parce que quasiment
tout vient de chine aura pas de la chine
vous aussi parler du japon je vais aussi
parler de la corée du sud qui sont des
pays importants dans ce domaine là mais
c'est avec la chine en termes de
fournisseurs ça reste quand même
relativement énorme ça monte aujourd'hui
la dépendance qu'on a envers un pays et
c'est assez flippant
je sais pas ce que vous en pensez alors
je dis pas c'est pas cette vidéo pour
alarmer tout le monde est vraiment en
faire un petit point
aujourd'hui un instant t shirt on est
début février pour essayer de voir un
peu où on en est voir comment les choses
se développent en tout cas ce qui est
sûr c'est que un homme averti en vaut
deux je me balade pas comme ça dans la
rue mais c'est sûr c'est que au mwc
je me pose la question donc d'un masque
on verra ça sur ce je vous embrasse
rendez vous dès demain sans rentrer sans
rien on continue à parler tech envie
d'amour à demain
à
[Musique]